atattendue que les premières
jojournées chaudes du printemps.
L Les drêches, les céréales
rerejetées après la fermentation
dede la bière, sont mélangées
avavec d'autres ingrédients...
..... et servies auxux vaches
dede la ferme Lahaise,
dadans Lanaudière.
L Les animaux se régalent,
leles drêches évitent
l'l'enfouissement,
etet le producteur laitier,
lului, calcule les économies
ququ'il réalise.
PAPATRICK LAHAISE,
prproducteur laitier
- - La drêche est un produit,
ququand même, qui est compétiti.
PuPuis, c'est un produit
ququi remplace un peu tous
leles ingrédients qu'il y a
àà la ferme. Donc, ça permet
dede réduire les importations
àà la ferme de maïs,
leles importations de tourteau
dede soja, les importations
d'd'autres sources de protéines,
sosouvent, qui viennent
dede l'extérieur.
- - En plus d'être riche
enen protéines, elle se vend
dede quatre à dix fois moins
chchère que le maïs ou le soja.
MaMais la majorité des drêches
dedes grandes brasseries
ququébécoises, Molson Coors
etet Labatt, sont écoulées...
auaux États-Unis.
DADANIEL FRÉCHETTE, agronome,
didir. des ventes, Furst-McNess
- - Nos plus gros clients,
prprésentement, c'est des grosss
fefermes laitières dans l'État
dudu Vermont et dans l'État
dede New York. Je vous dirais
ququ'il y a à peu près 80 %...
8585 % de notre volume total
dede ces deux entités-là
sosont exportés aux États-Unis.
- - Daniel Fréchette achète
dedes produits alimentaires
ququ'il revend au secteur
agagricole. C'est lui qui gère
leles drêches des gros joueurs.
ChChaque semaine, il compte ente
5050 et 55 camions-remorques
dede 35 tonnes chacun qui
trtraversent la frontière.
- - Ce qu'on voit, c'est qu'il a
dedes sous-produits qui passent
enen camion devant les fermes,
prprobablement, qui devaient...
ququi pourraient avoir
ceces produits-là.
- - Un constat qui désole
dede nombreux producteurs
bobovins et laitiers.
JEJEAN-THOMAS MALTAIS, président
dedes producteurs bovin du Québc
- - Les fermes au Québec,
onon a pendant longtemps
unun peu levé le nez sur les so-
prproduits. On est habitués
avavec nos coopératives,
pupuis nos meuleries,
d'd'avoir des produits complets,
dedes moulées déjà toutes
babalancées. Fait que
l'l'utilisation de sous-produits
esest... on est en retard,
sésérieusement.
- - L'explosion du prix des
inintrants pourrait-elle forcer
unun dialogue? À première vue,
totous le souhaitent.
- - Mais tout est dans
lala mentalilité, puis c'est sûr
ququ'il y a une industrie qui et
dédéjà présente, que je vous
didisais, il y a des réseaux
dede meuniers, il y a des réseax
ququi sont bien établis avec
dedes... des représentants
ququi sont bien formés, qui i st
dadans le... qui font une très
bobonne "job". Mais il y a quand
mmême un ajustement à faire.
- - Un ajustement que la plus
grgrande coopérative agricole
cacanadienne n'est pas prête
àà faire pour le moment.
"L"Le marché n'est pas là,
didit Sollio Groupe Coopératif,
auautrefois appelée "La Coop
FéFédérée", qui consnseille et d
dedes produits aux agriculteurs.
LeLes enjeux logisistiques sontp
grgrands, dit-elle, pour que ce
sosoit une avenue économiquement
inintéressante."
I Ici Maude Montembeault,
R Radio-Canada, Baie-du-Febvr